uh so thank you for the opportunity to
speak to you today about
dengue virus and host responses to
dengue virus
my name is ashley st john i am associate
professor in the program in emerging
infectious diseases at duke and u.s
medical school in singapore
so
we know that dengue is caused by dengue
virus it's one of the most prevalent
pathogens in the world born by
mosquitoes and in fact the most
prevalent viral pathogen
and in fact most people who experience
dingy may not even know that they have
had a dengue infection
but in rare cases
you know complications can develop and
usually these involve vascular
complications
so you can see on here on the right side
some of the signs and symptoms of severe
dengue including vascular leakage and
hemorrhaging
you know so up in the up in the left
hand corner you can see
some images from a publication with an
autopsy where they looked at various
organs after
death due to dengue and you can see that
there's a good bit of hemorrhaging in
the panel a um they're showing the gut
in panel b you can see the kidney and
that there's quite a bit of hemorrhaging
there inside the kidney
in panel c this is the liver with
what looks almost like bruising on the
surface but this is due to the
microvascular permeability and
hemorrhaging and in panel d it's really
quite severe these are the lungs so this
is worst case scenario with dengue but
there's quite a spectrum of disease and
many immunological complications
including rash
and fever
so we know that
a small portion of people will develop
severe disease but usually we think of
those processes that result in severe
disease as beginning earlier and being
immune mediated so you can see in these
time courses of infection
what happens to an individual when
they're experiencing dengue so after the
mosquito bite there's a period of time
that's an incubation period
before the onset of fever but during
this time the immune response is
responding to dengue
detecting it and beginning to initiate
the adaptive immune response which can
come up
you know within a week to two weeks
following infection so uh
importantly there are four different
serotypes of dengue so that means that
you can experience four different types
of infection in a lifetime theoretically
and usually
one dengue immunity to one dinghy
infection can be protective against the
same
serotype of dengue but is not protective
and may even
be associated with more severe disease
during a secondary dengue infection so
you can see here on the bottom how these
curves are shifted although veremia may
be a shorter period of time
there is a heightened risk of shock and
hemorrhage in those individuals who are
experiencing a secondary dengue
infection and importantly this risk of
shock and hemorrhage usually occurs uh
towards the towards the end of the
disease time course as viremia is
subsiding and as the fever is subsiding
so uh you know my lab is quite
interested in these early time points
what happens immediately following the
mosquito bite and how that can set up
for this downstream severe disease
so when
a mosquito bites and injects
dengue into the skin it's not unopposed
there's uh a good bit of the immune
system that is there ready and waiting
to respond and so you can see here in a
whole mounted tissue of skin how the
blood vessels are in blue and they form
a very dense network and this is what
the mosquito is probing and trying to
find
but
in close proximity to blood vessels are
immune cells and this image is one type
of immune cell which is called the mast
cell
and mast cells are distributed lining
blood vessels throughout the connective
tissues in the body very very densely in
the skin about the same density as
dendritic cells and macrophages which
are discussed perhaps a little more
often
when we talk about mast cells we usually
talk about their role in allergic
responses
how they detect these innocuous
environmental antigens such as shown at
the bottom
and result in the diseases that we call
asthma allergy anaphylaxis or contact
hypersensitivity um which are all
thought to be mast cell mediated and
usually in those contexts mast cells
might not respond to these antigens
alone but they do so through interaction
with a unique subclass of antibodies
called ige
and this induces cross-linking of the fc
receptors that are shown here on the
surface of the mast cell and can trigger
mast cell degranulation
so this is
at the top an image of mast cell
degranulation
by scanning electron microscopy so you
can see on the left in panel a a resting
mast cell where they have all of these
little granules that are right under the
surface they're
ready to go
so this mast cell is armed and these
granules contain inflammatory mediators
not just cytokines and chemokines which
are also there but in addition to that
many uh proteases and anticoagulants
such as heparin and you can see in panel
b once a mast cell has been activated it
releases all of these uh little granules
in a very explosive reaction that
happens just within seconds and you can
see the granules remain slightly
insoluble
they're you know on the surface of the
slide here but you can imagine in the
body these
really acts like a slow release pill
where the molecules that are inside the
granules very slowly diffuse away and
have you know activity inside the tissue
that is pro-inflammatory
so at the bottom you can also see how
mast cells respond to dengue virus on
the left again the control tissue that's
stained with a probe for the mast cell
granules and you can see that the
granules are very tightly packed around
the nucleus of each of these two mast
cells in the control tissue but on the
right hand side the mast cell that is
activated by dengue and you can see that
the dengue antigen is stained here in
red using this uh
antibody 4g ii which is a dengue
specific
envelope specific antibody
we can see that all these little tiny
granules have been released in the
surrounding tissue
so i'm going to for the sake of time
just summarize some of our early
findings on how mast cells respond to
dengue
and that is that we saw that they're
very highly protective in the skin
during cutaneous dengue infection so
when the mosquito injects muscles are
activated they release these granules
these have a pro-inflammatory effect in
the skin at the local site and that
promotes viral clearance at the early
stages
particularly we get recruitment of these
cells in the corner in k cells and t
cells
and in kt cells
which
clear the infection and
prevent the virus from spreading to the
draining lymph nodes to the same extent
so we get much lower levels of early
viral infection in animals that
have mast cells compared to mast cell
deficient animals
and many of the mediators that are
involved in the recruitment of these
cells we highlighted here on the side
and these are also de novo synthesized
in addition to the granules that mast
cells have with proteases inside
so um but today i want to talk about the
pathology that's associated with dengue
hemorrhagic fever and uh when i first
started this project now over more than
10 years ago
we were questioning uh you know this
unique spectrum of disease you see with
dengue actually has some similarities to
other
pathological contacts particularly
allergic diseases and anaphylaxis so you
can see here on the left in panels a and
b how this individual who has dengue um
is experiencing a pretty severe rash
on their skin and in the panel below
that
hello
this patient has a bleeding into the
eyes so this is a microvascular
hemorrhaging here in the eyes and these
sorts of things happen as well during
very severe allergic reactions
and in those conditions
mast cells we know are very essential
for disease as i mentioned
in part because they release all of
these mediators
including things such as histamine tnf
the proteases i talked about
leukotrienes which are also important
for vascular effects heparin
again an anticoagulant and others and we
know that together these mediators can
break tight junctions between
endothelial cells they can reduce
clotting
so based on that we wanted to first
question whether mast cells are
contributing to vascular leakage during
dengue infection and for this we use
mice that are deficient in mast cells
they have a genetic deficiency so they
don't have
any mast cells
and in this case we saw that
when we measure vascular leakage here in
this particular panel on the top right
we're measuring vascular leakage by
hematocrit which is
the concentration of the blood that is
red blood cells so you can imagine that
as you lose
the fluid in the blood vessels
as the plasma seeps out through
blood vessels that are more permeable
you end up with a higher concentration
of red blood cells
that are remaining in the blood and so
this hemo concentration is observed in
wild-type mice
that are dengue infected but we do not
see this in mast cell deficient mice and
this strongly points to mast cells as
being
an essential contributor to vascular
leakage in this animal model
and down below
we also wanted to look in humans and try
to determine whether mast cells are
activated in humans
for this we had a group of patients in
singapore and very uniquely
these patients
could be classified into having dengue
fever or mild disease or dingy
hemorrhagic fever which is really severe
disease and what initially we wanted to
just uh use a biomarker of mast cell
activation and this
we particularly used this protease which
is called chimase
this is a
really mast cell specific molecule that
is made by mast cells and stored in
their granules and not made by other
cells
and we thought it can be a biomarker of
mast cell activation and we'll
understand then if humans are
experiencing mast cell activation during
dengue infection and so indeed you can
see both patients with dhf and
dengue fever as well have heightened
levels of mast cell activation but one
important um observation was that this
seemed to correlate with severity so
that those patients with dengue
hemorrhagic fever had much higher levels
of climate in their serum
than patients with a milder dengue fever
and this really suggests that muscle
activation itself is correlated with the
severity of disease
so one other thing i told you at the
beginning is associated with severe
disease
is previous infection and
there are many different ways that it is
thought that antibodies could possibly
contribute to severe disease when you
have a secondary heterologous infection
so this cartoon shows this you can see
uh during a primary infection uh
infection by one serotype will generate
an immune memory and part of that memory
response includes the the production of
antibodies that are specific against the
first serotype
and
again on the right hand side at the top
where it says secondary homologous
infection what this diagram is showing
is that during a secondary infection
with the same stereotype
we are able to see neutralization and
blocking of infection by these
antibodies so they're very effective in
preventing re-infection
but
during a secondary heterologous
infection it's a very different story
first we can see a phenomenon that's
called antibody dependent enhancement of
infection and in this uh scenario we
know that that when you have infection
with the second serotype you can get
binding of these antibodies to that
serotype but they may not be protective
and in fact they can cause a process
called optimization
which is when these immune complexes of
antibody and virus are taken up
by
cells that express the fc receptors such
as dendritic cells monocytes or
macrophages
and this can actually lead to enhanced
infection of those cells
leading to you know worse and severity
of disease these antibodies can also uh
over here on the far right side you can
see
decorate uh infected cells and lead to
uh in case cell-mediated killing of
those cells uh which could in induce a
great deal of cytokine release and
inflam inflammation associated with the
death of these infected cells but what
i'm going to talk to you about at length
today is this process is depicted right
in the middle at the bottom of this
slide which is mast cell mediated
activation by immune complexes and we're
going to talk about how we should that
this occurs in detail
so we know that mast cell activation is
enhanced by ige but an important point
is that it's also enhanced by igg
and so you can see in the top graph
where
we have
used increasing concentrations of this
antibody 4g2 which again i mentioned is
a cross-reactive antibody that binds to
all of the different serotypes of dengue
you can see that
in the presence of increasing
concentrations of antibody we have
increasing mast cell degranulation and
that's shown here at the bottom as well
where in the control cells the cranials
are very nice and tightly packed inside
the mast cells
but with dengue activation we begin to
see release of these granules onto the
slide around this mast cell that's been
activated by the virus and then on the
far right you can appreciate that this
is much more extreme in the presence of
a enhancing antibody
well it's not
oops
it's not only
the
it's not only the muscle degranulation
that's enhanced it's also
the
vascular leakage so when we use this in
vivo model sash mites here are to
indicate the mast cell deficient mice
and we compared them to wild-type mice
um and we measured their vascular
leakage after dengue infection so on the
left we use hematocrit which i spoke
about previously and on the right we
used evan's blue dye which is a
injectable dye that you can then detect
as it leaks into tissues and again in
the wild type which is shown here in
magenta we can see that there is a
significant increase in with dengue
alone uh when we give it with just an
isotype control antibody that's not
specific i mean and that we saw
previously as well but in the presence
of uh antibody we get greatly enhanced
vascular leakage
and again this is shown by both of the
methods in contrast in the sash mice
which lack mast cells not only do we
lose the
direct
vascular leakage that's mast cell
dependent so that the infection alone
induces uh
vascular leakage that's really close to
the baseline
but again we lose the antibody enhanced
component of that as well and again
that's shown
with the turquoise color
in both of these two scenarios
so
um an important point is that this is
really happening through the mast cells
receptor for igg so you can see on the
left hand side we treated mast cells
with
a
this 4g ii antibody that crossed reacts
between different dengue serotypes and
we challenged them with the muscles then
with dengue and you can see that both
dengue alone and the uv inactivated
dengue induced a significant increase in
degranulation above the baseline level
caused by dengue alone
and then you know the overall baseline
is shown by this gray line at the middle
but when we use
mast cells particularly bone marrow
drive mast cells that lack
the fc gamma r3 receptor which is the
activating sc receptor on mast cells for
detecting igg immune complexes we can
see that this antibody dependent
enhancement is lost
so
again we can uh test this in vivo so
we made mast cells from either wild-type
mice or
fc gamma r3 knockout mice
and after generating those mast cells we
injected them into mast cell deficient
mice and this allows engraftment of
those mast cells and in that context we
can then see the function of the mast
cells in vivo and animals themselves
after infection
we also then sensitize these animals
with an antibody against dengue and
followed by a dengue challenge and so
you can see here in those animals that
are reconstituted
with the esee gamma r3 knockout
bone marrow drive mast cells we see
far reduced vascular leakage again in
terms of the hematocrit
readings as well as the dye leakage into
the tissues so this really suggests that
mast cells can be activated by immune
complexes that antibodies
are able to enhance the mast cell's
effect on the vasculature
during dengue infections
and then we also went back to our dengue
cohort
and we looked at those patients that had
dhf and we split those patients into
those that were having a primary dengue
infection and those that were having a
secondary dengue infection and this was
determined serologically in advance
and we saw that when we
compare the levels of climate uh which
are analogous to the levels of mast cell
activation
it's much heightened in the context of
secondary dengue infection compared to a
primary dengue infection so even for
those severe patients
the ones that are having a secondary
infection are having much higher levels
of mast cell activation
so uh just to summarize this part so far
we can see that mast cells mediate
enhanced pathology during secondary
dengue infection the dengue specific igg
can augment the release of mast cell
products this seems to happen through
activating fc receptors on the surface
of mast cells and we think this is
another mechanism for how
mast cell how antibodies can exacerbate
immune pathology during secondary dengue
infection and one that is mast cell
dependent so i still want to emphasize
that early in infection we do know that
mast cells are
highly protective when the infection is
localized and it's early in the disease
time course
but we also see that their products can
contribute to severe disease and i think
this is very similar to many other
immunological contexts that we think
about where we know that the immune
system is is protective it does protect
us against infection but that
occasionally
when it's
activated in a heightened way
or an aberrant way it can lead to immune
pathologies that are detrimental
and so the next question we had was
which of these products that are
elicited by dengue from mast cells
actually are causing this vascular
leakage and hemorrhaging
in particular
we focused in immediately on something
that is mast cell specific we wanted to
look at the mast cell proteases because
we thought
you know while many cytokines and lipid
mediators can be made in the context of
infection by numerous cell types if
we're looking at something mass cell
dependent we really wanted to view it
from the perspective of understanding
which mast cell specific products could
be contributing
so two of the products that we focused
on are proteases um tryptase for example
and chymase
chymase is an angiotensin-converting
enzyme tryptase is uh known to cleave
par receptors between endothelial cells
and both of these have uh you know other
functions in vivo
that are pro-inflammatory so to begin to
understand which of these could be
inducing the endothelial permeability
that we observe during dengue we started
by culturing primary endothelial cells
on
as a monolayer and you can see we imaged
them here we stained them for the
tubulin which allows us to see their
structure uh the dappy for the nucleus
and also uh zo1 which is a tight
junction protein and that you can see
just ship is found at the border of the
cells it's important for holding these
cells together
and when we treat the cells that we've
created as a monolayer with either
tryptase or kymase we observe that both
of them were able to induce some degree
of permeability of these monolayers so
for example
on the left-hand side at high
concentration you can see that tryptase
has
really completely
eliminated this zo1 staining at the
border of cells and we can even see
cells peeling up off of
of the
[Music]
tissue culture plate um in the lower
concentration we start seeing some
punctate staining
between cells that really is indicative
that these
tight junctions are beginning to be
broken down and that's similar to what
we see at high concentrations of
climates
we also were curious if this happens in
vivo so to begin with uh we
produced uh tryptase and kymase uh as
recombinant proteins to inject into
recipient animals in the absence of
dengue infection and what we observed is
that
given the same concentration
of tryptacerchimaes
there was a significant increase in the
hematocrit
or vascular leakage in vivo that was
entirely dependent on the protein itself
importantly uh
this tryptace and khymis were given
concentrations very similar to what's
observed in dhf patients and we saw that
at the same dose uh tryptase was much
more effective inducing vascular leakage
compared to climates and and this did
not occur with an innocuous control
protein which we used here which is
ovalbumin
similarly
we also borrowed from some of the
allergy and anaphylaxis literature where
a drop in temperature is a key marker of
um
of shock and can be used to read out the
the presence of shock after anaphylaxis
and so we wanted to use that system here
when we injected tryptace and kymase we
noted that there was a very significant
drop in temperature that's indicative of
shock that
occurred at the same level of tryptase
that is observed in dhf patients so this
really showed us that
both tryptace and khymit can induce
vascular leakage but tryptase is much
more strongly associated with shock
and this also occurred in humans so we
used some serum samples to test for for
tryptase and uh these patients were
graded according to the severity of the
dhs that they experienced so grade two
dhf is associated with vascular leakage
and hemorrhaging but not necessarily
with shock
grade 3 dhf is associated with shock but
grade 4 dhf is very severe it involves
shock
in the absence of a pulse and is
is indicative of um
circulatory failure
in contrast to that uh fatal
fatal dhf is really very similar to
grade four and and there's not a
distinguishing feature other than the
survival so you can see here that
there's a very strong correlation
between the levels of serum tryptase and
the grade of shock that the patients
were experiencing
so then the next question is of course
if mast cells are contributing to dengue
immune pathology are we able to target
mast cells to limit
the disease and this is an exciting
possibility because we know that there
are many many drugs that are on the
market already that target either mast
cells or their products and they've been
used
in the clinic for decades and they're
very safe so some of these include mast
cell stabilizers uh such as chromoline
and ketotin
leukotriene receptor antagonists and tnf
blockers and so we wanted to test
different types of drugs and identify
those that might be effective against
dengue
this is one of our first studies we did
you can see that
in animal models that were infected with
dengue we treated this is a mouse model
with either chrome one ketotiphan or
tnf we also used separately that's not
shown here the leukotriene receptor
antagonist and we saw that only
the chromoline and ketotophen were very
highly effective in blocking vascular
leakage by both of our different methods
in terms of evidence
dye leakage into the tissues as well as
the hematocrit
we also know that uh in animals that are
infected with dengue were able to detect
very striking changes that occur with
respect to the transcriptional processes
happening in the spleen shown here as an
example but also the liver and other
target organs and many of these pathways
that are induced such as the interferon
response pathway cytokine responses and
lipid metabolism we saw were reduced or
reversed
in in the presence of ketotin
as a mast cell stabilizing drug
we also used a tryptace inhibitor we
used a drug called nafamostat mesolithic
and in this case uh we gave the animals
in the thermostat methylate and tested
the enzymatic activity of tryptase we
saw in panel b here that it was reduced
and
and when they were treated we could
again measure the vascular leakage and
you can see in panel a a very
significant drop in vascular leakage in
the presence of nephamosthat methylate
and this really affected the vascular
leakage specifically for example another
sign of severe dengue is a
thrombocytopenia or a drop in platelets
and you can see that was not affected so
this effect on tryptace was very
specifically associated with the uh
preventing vascular leakage and in
penalty you can see that this
inhibition occurred without greatly
affecting
the viral titers itself
and what this looks like in vivo we can
measure
with a video the
vascular leakage over time so over time
you can see in the control in the very
top panel we just see the blood uh
flowing through the blood vessels but we
don't see vascular leakage at the steady
state
in the presence of dengue however over
time after dye injection you can see
that these images captured at different
times show the gradual leakage of the
dye into the tissue itself but this is
completely prevented in the context of
nephamostat mesolate treatment and
that's just shown here quantitatively
where over time you can see the green
line shows an increase in the leakage of
the dye whereas the blue line shows that
this uh the famous that methylate is
able to completely protect against
vascular leakage
so some key points i wanted to make to
to
summarize are that massive proteases are
really key for dengue-induced vascular
leakage
we know that the mast cell activation is
a strong correlate of dengue severity um
one point i'd like to make is that most
of these serum samples that we collected
and that i showed you um that data was
collected at very early time points so
before the patients actually develop
severe disease and so we think kaimase
is a really strong candidate as an early
biomarker of disease severity and that
perhaps some of the processes that are
being initiated by inflammation early on
are are climace dependent and then again
we see tryptase which is not as strong
of a biomarker just because of its
kinetics of breakdown quick
quick breakdown in vivo but it seems to
be very important
for
actually developing vascular leakage
and is strongly associated with shock
particularly
so um between these two proteases we
think that this uh these are possible uh
promising therapeutic targets
for preventing severe dengue and this is
something that our group is continuing
to study
so i just want to
summarize a bit what we know about
vascular leakage during dengue and the
immune pathology associated with it so
we know that there are innate processes
that can regulate vascular leakage for
example when the virus infects target
cells we know that we can have the
production of pro-inflammatory mediators
such as interferons such as cytokines
and the virus proteins themselves
including products such as
ns1 they may directly act on various
cell types in the body and cause some
aspects of the pathology that we observe
and associate with dengue we also know
that people who are having a secondary
dengue infection
can have more severe disease and i
talked about several ways that
antibodies can do this
both by enhancing infection and also
through enhancing mast cell activation
but t cells are an important component
as well perhaps the t cell response and
the memory t cell response can also lead
to enhanced activation and release of
pro-inflammatory mediators in the
context of secondary infection and some
of these could contribute as well to the
pathology but i think central to
what we have studied is the mast cell
which really bridges this innate and
adaptive response being able to both
detect
dengue at baseline as well as respond to
it in an enhanced fashion in the
presence of
bodies and that these products that are
released
mast cell proteases which are pre-stored
and may not be detected as part of a
transcriptional response that is
measured um are also contributing
factors to the vascular leakage that we
observe
and so with that i uh would like to
acknowledge my lab
particularly uh chiang mai and wilfried
who did much of this work abe rator
who's now at duke university did all of
the trip days work
and juliet morrison who is now at uc
riverside has
been very instrumental in helping us
look at our transcriptional responses
so with that i will i will finish thank
you